est ce que ça vous choque de voir
aujourd'hui des travestis au coeur de
paris oh non ça me choque a énormément
c'est lui qui a ramené décida ici c'est
toi surtout les brésiliens aujourd'hui
ils sont dans paris car le bois est
fermé je ne peux pas vous répondre ça
c'est du travail ici sont les brésiliens
qui ont été expulsés du bois qui
maintenant sont au coeur de paris vous
envahissent avenue victor hugo et les
boulevards d'auteuil et ça revient au
même
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de leur
dire à ces gens là du cici ce travail
mené leur dire venez de dire
roberto roberto c'est bien vouloir te
dire quelque chose où travaille ou ce
travail maintenant et c'est parce que
les bois les fermes
ça c'est pas beau ici on a des enfants
ici mais aussi les enfants
sa feinte 50 cent les enfants tu fais
vous avez des enfants et bien sûr j'ai
des enfants fait plaisir des pensées qui
veulent se faire l'épongé leurs petits
boyaux pour 50 prend maintenant on n'a
pas du tout je n'aime pas ce travail je
suis musulman j'appelle ça ce mois ici
c'est un quartier et font également les
musulmans s'est travesti envahissent la
capitale puisque le bois est maintenant
fermée vous pensez que c'est une bonne
solution que de les voir à guichet
absolument pas c'est ridicule
allez vous rhabiller part de cochon
venez venez veineuse cette dame est
contre le fait que vous soyez dans les
rues de paris
absolument c'est dégueulasse absolument
et moi je trouve ça monstrueux de faire
ce que vous faites
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
madame personnellement est ce que vous
vous avez déjà eu affaire à des
prostituées non est-ce que vous même
vous êtes un travesti non vous pouvez le
prouver ça ne vous regarde pas vous
étiez-vous clients de ces gens là non
j'y allais fond de marée quoi pour me
marrer c'est quoi pour vous marrer on
allait traîner à plusieurs copains jeu
il ya des vitraux autour on à lui faire
le con maintenant plein bistrot le bois
de boulogne bien sûr c'est bien connu
irez vous ferrez projet de loi remplit
facilement ma tante est centrale non
mais on le sent prix réel ça vous
stresse pas de penser votre petit copain
un peu des sentiers sphère sociale
n'importe quelle heure maintenant que
c'est en bas de la maison ça me stresse
pas mais bon c'est de se passer ça se
passera
un client potentiel sur moi c'est un
scandale d'avoir fait le bordel qu'ils
ont fait au bois de boulogne qu'est ce
que ça veut dire
tout est gentil tu viens sans fin la
pipe de sevran la pipe je vais safran la
pipe de 130 sans les quatre potes de ce
nom avec la capote
on y va je vous laisse à votre destin
merci beaucoup
bonsoir il va déshabiller regarder ah
bah vous voyez je viens de regarder
comprenez combien vous pour une pige à
meilleur marché
ok on va y aller alors et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus